you think the reason they're not is just
purely embarrassed the fact that this is
gonna
lose lose even more credibility with the
audience that what we've been saying
this entire time we've been wrong we
haven't done real true investment no i
don't know i don't think that's it i
think no i don't think that's it if if
that was the reason
i could understand that reason
i think it's part of this
implicit and explicit collusion it's
like this isn't the story and so we're
not going to report it and i think that
economically even that's a foolish
decision because newsweek i've been
reading newsweek recently newsweek has
some journalists they actually have some
real information again which is quite
interesting
though it's still a liberal magazine
yeah but
my experience has been in the last
couple of months i thought oh my god
there's some actual news in newsweek and
so that was that was really cool
but i see all this
not only as collusion which is
absolutely appalling so that's the death
of journalism because journalists are
colluding with politicians it's like
well they're not journalists anymore and
they're also not politicians because if
they were politicians and journalists
they wouldn't be colluding whatever they
are as a consequence of this collusion
is not politicians and journalists it's
some completely new thing now i'm less
worried about it than i might be because
i also see it as part of the inevitable
death spiral of the legacy media
they're dead and why well
they don't have a monopoly over
the dissemination of information at all
youtube for all of its flaws which are
manifold is an unbelievably powerful and
accessible
technology where the cost of entry is
zero it's like no tv station can compete
with that period they're done and then
these print media sources especially
when their great people barry weiss
might be example leave because they
can't say what they want to they don't
have to lose much of their talent before
all they've got left is hacks and then
everyone can publish to an international
audience instantly online
so part of what we're seeing in the
mainstream media is a technologically
fueled death spiral and i know how large
corporations die so
there's this principle pareto principle
which is that
the square root of the number of people
in a given creative enterprise do half
the work and so if you're a news
organization with a thousand people 30
of them do half the work and you think
no and you can think that all you want
but you're just wrong because this is
one of the most well established
findings in social science period
so you got a thousand people and 970 of
them are putting in time and 30 of them
are doing half the work and then
something shifts
those people can't say what they want to
say let's say the 30. the 30. what do
they do well they leave why because they
can
right these are people they're un these
are competent people they're really
smart they're on the edge they're tough
they have immense networks of
connections as soon as the ship rocks
they think ciao you think i need you
it's like you got you got your
priorities wrong you need me they go off
like barry weiss did and start their own
thing and so then you're left with the
970 that was only doing half the work
and then the next 30 competent people
leave and soon all you've got is people
who
run the legacy media and they just and
they say things like well joe rogan
people shouldn't listen to him because
he just wings it it's like how clueless
can you possibly be
or or you have people like at cnn who
treat rogan like he's an outsider
despite the fact that he's pulling in
numbers that are at least five five to
eight times their average viewership
joe is fringe it's like really we'll see
who's fringe here and so and part of
this is purely technological it's like
there's no way these legacy
apparatuses
can compete
how can they
printing is for printing with universal
distribution is free video with
universal distribution is free how can a
network possibly compete it can't so
spiral death and as they die they lose
their editors they lose their fat fact
checkers they lose their good
journalists they lose everybody with
courage and then they put out pablum and
they and they're tempted by click bait
because that's what you have to do while
you're dying it's like christ we have to
attract attention somehow so you say
well joe rogan apologized and everybody
clicks on it and they read it and they
think that's a lie and so you've lost
another five percent of your viewership
cnn is probably sitting in their board
meetings saying
god please we need trump to be president
again because when he was president we
were making money
we we need somebody like that to be
president they're begging this guy to
come back can you imagine if cnn
ends up like putting him on left and
right too and then you know to berate
him but at the same time they're getting
more eyeballs so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]